This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantantham. What comes to your mind when I say the words, holophame? Maybe the rock and roll holophame and Cleveland, Ohio? Or the NASCAR holophame and Charlotte North Carolina? Music, sports, these make sense. For today's show, I want to take you to an unusual holophame. It's a New York City.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当我提到“名人堂”（holophame）这个词时，你首先会想到什么？也许是克利夫兰的摇滚名人堂？还是北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的NASCAR名人堂？音乐、体育，这些都说得通。但在今天的节目中，我想带大家去一个不寻常的名人堂，它位于纽约市。
It pops up only once a year, and it's the kind of attraction you might smell before you see it. And this year what you're looking at with all the danger tape all over it is the Hall of Fumes. The Hall of Fumes is located in the Ripley's Believe It or Not Museum in Times Square. To be honest, it's not really a hall. It's a metal rack holding up dozens of tattered, stinky sneakers. And these are the winners from all the past 42 years up until now. This is Rachel Hurst.
它一年只开放一次，而且这种景点的特点往往是“闻味而至”。今年，你看到贴满警戒线的地方就是“恶臭名人堂”。恶臭名人堂位于时代广场的雷普利信不信由你博物馆。老实说，它其实算不上什么大厅，而是一个挂着几十双破烂、发臭运动鞋的金属架。这些都是从过去42年一直到现在的历届冠军鞋。这位是蕾切尔·赫茨。
Then I'm here judging the 43rd Rotten Sneaker contest as the odor judge because for the past 11 years I have been the celebrity knows who gets to smell the stinkiest feet in the country. Contestants have to be between the ages of 8 and 15. Let's bring up our free season 7! Come on up! The six finalists are the 2018 competition qualified after winning similar contests at State Ferris. Rachel is here to judge only the Creme de la Creme.
作为气味评委，我在这里评选第43届腐臭运动鞋大赛，因为在过去的11年里，我一直都是那个有幸闻闻全美最臭脚丫的名人评委。参赛者的年龄必须在8到15岁之间。让我们请出我们的第三位选手！快上台吧！这六位决赛选手是通过在各州集市上赢得同类比赛，从而获得2018年决赛资格的。蕾切尔来这里只评选精英中的精英。
The kids have to actually hand me their sneaker. I pick it up with a pair of tongs because it's, you know, I wouldn't really want to touch it. Even though I'm wearing rubber gloves, I really don't want to touch it. Can you tell everyone just how you've got this shoe, so dirty and run? So I've waited a lot. I wore them over the summer without any socks. So then I take it and I stick my nose as close to it as I possibly can, which is I try not to get right in there because I can smell it usually from quite far away and then I sniff and then I rate it on a scorching. You might be wondering how Rachel landed this coveted gig.
孩子们必须亲手把他们的运动鞋交给我。我是用一对钳子把它拿起来的，因为，你知道的，我其实不太想碰它。尽管我戴着橡胶手巾，但我真的不想碰它。你能告诉大家你是怎么把鞋子弄得这么脏这么破的吗？所以我穿了很多次。我在夏天穿它们时从来不穿袜子。然后我把它拿起来，把鼻子尽可能凑近。我尽量不直接贴上去，因为我通常在很远的地方就能闻到味，然后我闻一闻，接着给它打分。你可能想知道蕾切尔是怎么得到这份令人艳羡的工作的。
She's a psychologist affiliated with Brown University and Boston College and she's extensively researched the human senses of smell and taste and the emotion of disgust. Who doesn't have a freeze that forward please? I will take this but you sneak her on the tray? Oh, that's horrible. That's horrible. I have to go out of my mouth. Now I don't even have to smell the shoe to feel disgusted.
她是布朗大学和波士顿学院的心理学家，曾广泛研究人类的嗅觉、味觉以及厌恶情绪。请大家往前进一点好吗？我能把这双鞋放在托盘上吗？哦，太可怕了。太可怕了。我得走到嘴巴外面去了。现在，我甚至不用去闻那只鞋就能感到恶心。
The thought repulses me. That's how Rachel fell too before she judged her first contest 11 years ago. I had really, really psyched myself up to think, okay, this is going to be the worst thing that you could imagine. Just don't worry, it's going to be over soon. And when I went to smell the sneakers, they actually, I mean, they weren't good by any means. But they were not as bad as my mind had prepared me to assume that they would be. What I realized is that it's our minds that have so much control over what we think is disgusting and how we approach something as disgusting. Today on Hidden Brain, we know it's around the topic of disgust.
这种想法就让我退避三舍。在11年前第一次担任评委之前，蕾切尔也是这种感觉。我当时真的、真的很给自己做心理建设，心想：好吧，这将会是你想象中最糟糕的事情。别担心，一会儿就过去了。而当我真去闻那些运动鞋时，其实——我的意思是，它们绝谈不上好闻。但它们并没有我的大脑预想的那么糟糕。我意识到，正是我们的大脑在很大程度上控制了我们对“什么是恶心”的认知，以及我们如何看待恶心之物。今天在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们的探讨主题正是“厌恶”。
Why do some things like smelly sneakers disgust us, while other things, like smelly pieces of cheese, delight us. And we learn why Rachel calls disgust. The instinct that has to be learned. There's a simple explanation for why we have the emotion of disgust. It's a defense mechanism against things that could contaminate us. But we often have flawed intuitions about how disgust works, starting with what's clean and what's dirty. In her book, that's disgusting, Rachel Hearst talks about how the cleanliness of toilet
为什么像臭运动鞋这样的一些东西会让我们感到恶心，而另一些东西，比如臭奶酪，却能取悦我们？我们还将了解为什么蕾切尔将厌恶称作“必须后天习得的本能”。我们产生厌恶情绪其实有一个简单的解释，它是一种抵御可能污染我们的事物的防御机制。但我们对于厌恶机制往往有着错误的直觉，首先就是关于什么是干净、什么是肮脏的直觉。蕾切尔·赫茨在她的书《真恶心》（That's Disgusting）中谈到了马桶座圈的清洁度与自动取款机（ATM）按钮的对比。
seats compares to buttons on an ATM. Things that we actually touched a lot and have no idea or don't really think about how disgusting they are, things like ATM buttons actually are cell phones, are just petri dishes of pathogens and germs. And most of us do not clean our cell phones very often. And yet we have this idea because of the associations that we know very specifically between toilets and waste from the human body that toilets are really really filthy. And yet we don't give a second thought to things like keyboards or cell phones and other sorts of things that people are touching all
那些我们经常触摸、却根本不知道或从不认为它们有多恶心的东西，比如ATM按钮或者手机，其实就是病原体和细菌的培养皿。我们大多数人并不经常清洁手机。然而，由于我们内心非常明确地将马桶与人体排泄物联系在一起，我们便下意识地认为马桶真的、真的很脏。然而，对于键盘、手机以及人们一直在触摸、可能非常肮脏且具有传染性的其他东西，我们却连想都不会想。
the time and could be very dirty and contagious. I want to talk about a certain quality that disgusting things have Rachel, which is that they tend to almost infect the things around them. As the psychologist Paul Rosen, who's done a lot of work on disgust, says, a single cockroach will destroy the appeal of a bowl of cherries, but a single cherry doesn't make a bowl of cockroaches appealing. Why do disgusting things infect the things around them? Well, first I want to make a sort of fleshed out a point there that I think is really interesting and that is that good does not overpower evil. The way evil can overpower good. And so in fact, in other experiments by Paul Ross and he found that the idea, for instance, of how could you purify something like Hitler's
蕾切尔，我想谈谈恶心之物的一种特质，那就是它们往往会几乎“感染”周围的事物。正如在厌恶研究领域做了大量工作的心理学家保罗·罗赞所说：“一只蟑螂会毁掉一碗樱桃的诱人程度，但一只樱桃却无法让一碗蟑螂变得诱人。”为什么恶心之物会感染周围的事物？嗯，首先我想详细阐述一个我认为非常有趣的观点，那就是：善并不能压倒恶，就像恶能够压倒善那样。事实上，保罗·罗赞的其他实验发现，比如，你如何净化像希特勒的毛衣这样的东西？
sweater. So people are told that Hitler owned the sweater, and would you be willing to wear it under varying conditions? Or would you be, how when could it become okay? And no form of cleaning could make it okay. Mother Teresa, wearing it, could make it a little bit okay. But in the case of Hitler's sweater, it had to be totally destroyed and burned in order for it to be okay. So good does not sanctify bad in the way
人们被告知这件毛衣曾属于希特勒，在不同条件下你是否愿意穿它？或者它在什么情况下才能变得可以接受？没有任何形式的清洗能让它变得可以接受。如果特蕾莎修女穿过它，可能会让它稍微可以接受一点。但在希特勒毛衣的例子中，它必须被彻底销毁并烧毁，才能让人觉得可以接受。所以，善并不能像恶能够玷污善那样去净化恶。
that bad can sanctify good. Whereas just one spot of something bad, like a cockroach, for instance, in a glass of water or milk or anything else, has the capacity to destroy the whole thing. Because negativity is much more pervasive and powerful from the way that we are built. And this is in fact adaptive because it's better to be worried about things that can harm
然而，坏事的一个污点，比如一杯水或牛奶里掉进了一只蟑螂，就有能力毁掉整杯东西。因为从我们的生理结构来看，负面影响具有更强的弥漫性和威力。事实上，这种机制具有适应性，因为对可能伤害我们的事物保持警惕，总比对那些表面上看似仁慈的事物过度兴奋要好。蕾切尔，我记得几年前我做过一篇报道，探讨了一个稍微相关的观点。这是社会学家安·博斯的著作，她当时正在研究二手结婚戒指的市场。
us than overly excited about things such as, might be benevolent. I remember doing a story some years ago Rachel that looked at a slightly related idea. This was worked by the sociologist Anne Bow's and she was studying the market for used wedding rings. And she found that people were really reluctant to buy a wedding ring when they learned that the couple who had previously owned that wedding ring had gotten divorced. And people tended to want wedding rings where they had been some tragic love story, but the couple had been very happy together. So I'm not sure if it's exactly the same concept, but it really feels as if inanimate objects can sometimes carry with them the spirit, if you will.
她发现，当人们得知以前拥有这枚戒指的那对夫妻已经离婚时，他们会非常不愿意买这枚结婚戒指。人们往往倾向于购买那些曾有过悲剧爱情故事、但这对夫妻曾经非常幸福的结婚戒指。所以我不敢确定这是否完全是相同的概念，但它确实让人感觉，无生命的物体有时似乎真的会承载某种“精神”，如果你愿意这么称呼的话。
It's an unscientific idea, the spirit of living things. Well, actually it is very much the same concept, Shankar, and what you're talking about is something called sympathetic magic, which definitely plays a role in discussed and what we're disg about is something called sympathetic magic, which definitely plays a role in discussed and what we're disgusted by through association. The idea of once in contact, always in contact. So for example, the ring that was on the finger of the woman who had a terrible marriage and ended up getting divorced, somehow even though that ring is now in a jewelry shop, has nothing to do with that original couple whatsoever. The essence of that bad marriage is somehow still in the ring.
这是一种不科学的观点，即活物的精神。嗯，事实上这完全是同一个概念，香卡。你所谈论的是一种叫做“顺势巫术”的东西，它绝对在厌恶情绪中发挥着作用，而我们通过联想所厌恶的东西也是如此。这就是“一旦接触，便永远联系”的观点。举个例子，那枚戴在曾经历糟糕婚姻并最终离婚的女性手指上的戒指，尽管现在它躺在珠宝店里，与那个最初的夫妻没有任何关系，但那段糟糕婚姻的“本质”不知为何依然留在了戒指里。
And therefore, wearing that ring will therefore impart the bad marriage onto the new wearer. And somehow this spirit, as you said, will transcend and infect the new marriage. So it's again, it's a form of infection. You have a very simple and interesting thought experiment in your book, which is, I'm not disgusted at the thought that when I drink a glass of water, that there is saliva in my mouth. But if I spit in a glass of water,
因此，戴上这枚戒指就会将那段糟糕的婚姻“赋予”新的佩戴者。不知何故，正如你所说，这种精神会超越并感染新的婚姻。所以这再次证明，这是一种感染的形式。你的书里有一个非常简单有趣的思想实验：我不觉得当我喝一杯水时，水里有我嘴里的唾液是一件令人恶心的事情。但如果我把唾液吐进一杯水里，然后去喝那杯水，那就显得很恶心了。当然，在这两种情况下，最终结果完全是一样的：我的嘴里有水，水里有唾液。为什么在一个情况下觉得更恶心，而在另一个情况下不觉得呢？
and then I drink that glass of water, that seems disgusting. And of course, in both cases, it's exactly the same outcome. I have water in my mouth with saliva in my mouth. Why does it feel more disgusting in one case and not the other? So that's exactly a great point about the idea that disgust is about the outside coming in and contaminating our inside. So while the saliva and the water is in our mouth it's inside of us and even just take water out of the equation just the fact that you have saliva in your mouth right now we're all okay with that. But
这正是关于“厌恶本质上是外部事物进入并污染我们内部”这一观点的绝佳例证。因此，当唾液和水还在我们口中时，它是我们身体内部的一部分；甚至不把水算在内，仅仅是你现在嘴里有唾液这件事，我们大家都能接受。但是，
as soon as we spit that exact same saliva that's in our mouth into the glass, and then look at that, and then I'm telling you, now you should drink that, it all of a sudden, even though it's only been out in the air for seconds, has become contaminated by the outside and bringing it back into our body is now an entirely different proposition. And the fact, also, I think in this case that even though I know it's my saliva, it could be your saliva, it could be anybody else's saliva. Suddenly, it becomes equalized with all the saliva that I know is out there, that I definitely do not want in my mouth.
一旦我们把嘴里那完全相同的唾液吐进杯子里，然后看着它，接着我告诉你，现在你应该把它喝下去，突然之间，尽管它暴露在空气中仅仅几秒钟，它就已经被外部环境“污染”了，此时再把它带回我们的体内，就完全是另一码事了。而且，我认为在这种情况下还有一个事实：尽管我知道那是我的唾液，但它也可以是你的唾液，或是任何其他人的唾液。突然之间，它就与我所知道的外界所有的唾液划上了等号，而那些唾液是我绝对不想弄进嘴里的。
So if someone, for instance, is talking at you and spitting while they're talking enthusiastically, we're disgusted by the fact that some spit could touch us. Just like once our spit is outside of our mouth it becomes much less pleasant to think about taking it back in. There was a really interesting study done about sharing your toothbrush and this study found that so again the idea that you know you're having to have something in your mouth that somebody else had in their mouth and it was found that the person that one would least like to share your toothbrush with is the boss that you don't like. Followed by... so if you don't like your boss, you definitely do not
所以，举个例子，如果有人一边对你说话，一边情绪高涨地喷着唾沫星子，我们就会对可能接触到这些唾液感到恶心。就像一旦我们的唾液离开口腔，再考虑把它吞回肚子里就会变得很不愉快一样。曾有一项非常有趣的关于共用牙刷的研究发现，同样是那种“必须把别人放进嘴里的东西放进自己嘴里”的想法，结果发现，人们最不愿意共用牙刷的人选竟然是自己讨厌的老板。其次是……所以如果你讨厌你的老板，你绝对不想
want to show your toothbrush with him or her. However, the anchor person on your local news station, if they were attractive, was pretty fine to share a toothbrush with. And people in your direct family or your best friends were also okay to share a toothbrush with. And so this speaks to two things. One, familiarity and emotional connection. So people in your family or your best friends, you feel positively towards them. You're very familiar with them.
和她或他共用牙刷。然而，如果当地新闻节目的主播长得很吸引人，人们倒是挺乐意和他们共用牙刷的。直系亲属或最好的朋友之间的牙刷也是可以共用的。这说明了两点：第一，熟悉感和情感联系。对于家人或挚友，你会对他们抱有好感，对他们非常熟悉。因此，在他们的唾液周围，你会感到某种安全感。至于电视上那个长相好看的人——美丽等于健康等于可以接受。但如果你讨厌某个人，或者对方是个陌生人，他们更有可能带来污染，或者纯粹因为你讨厌他们——哪怕他们长相英俊、你知道他们非常健康，但只要你讨厌他们，
And therefore you sort of feel safe around their saliva. The good-looking person on the television beauty equals health equals okay. But the person that you dislike or the person who's a stranger is a lot likely to be either more contaminating or because you don't like them purely because you don't like them. They could be good-looking and you could know they're very healthy but if you don't like them then They could be good looking and you could know they're very healthy, but if you don't like them, then you don't want anything about them coming into you as in their toothbrush. Contacts is key when it comes to disgust. In October 1972, a plane crashed in an isolated region of the Andes mountain range.
你就不希望他们身上的任何东西进入你的体内，比如他们的牙刷。在谈到厌恶时，情境是关键。1972年10月，一架飞机在安第斯山脉的偏远地区坠毁。机上有45人，其中大多数是前往智利参加比赛的橄榄球运动员。许多乘客在撞击时丧生，由于严寒和食物日益匮乏，更多的人在随后的几天里死去。最终，16人在山里艰难存活了两个多月，他们的故事启发了许多电影、书籍和纪录片，比如历史频道制作的这一部。我说：“南多，我们存放巧克力和沙丁鱼罐头的储藏舱里什么都不剩了。”南多看着我的眼睛说：“卡利托斯，我想吃飞行员。”
There were 45 people on board, most of them rugby players traveling to Chile for a competition. Many passengers died upon impact, more died in the coming days because of the freezing cold and dwindling food supply. In the end, 16 people had to survive more than two months in the mountains, and their story has inspired movies, books, and documentaries like this one from the History Channel. I said Nando, there isn't anything left in the storage compartments where we kept the chocolates and the can of sardines that we had. And Nando of me in the eye and said, Carlitos, I want to eat the pilot.
那些萌生这个想法并试图说服其他成员这是他们唯一生存之道的幸存者们，做了两件事。第一，他们告诉大家，要这样想：你们正在吃的只是肉。所以不要把它当成一个人来看待，这就像我们不把吃牛猪肉想成是在吃某个具体的动物，而是把它当成猪肉和牛肉。所以这只是肉。第二，他们试图从另一种道德层面来为之辩解，他们说，如果同伴们的死不能以这种方式被用来潜在地帮助他们生存下去，那么他们的死就会变成一种彻底的浪费。
The people that had this idea and wanted to convince the other members that this was the only way they were going to survive did two things. One, they told the people to think of this as what you're doing is eating just meat. So don't think about this as a person, kind of connected to we don't think about eating cows and pigs, so much as we think of eating pork and beef. So this is just meat. And the second thing is that they try to justify this in another kind of a moral way by saying that the death of their compatriots was would have been sort of a complete waste if it couldn't be used in this way to potentially aid in their survival.
于是，起初虽然心怀抗拒，但随后所有人都加入了进来，吃掉了身边死者的遗体。他们做的另一件事是：我们立下了誓言。我们做了现在人们也会做的事。人们会向朋友、家人捐献血液，进行器官移植，你知道的。我们立下誓言，说道：好吧，手拉手。如果我死了，请用我的身体。
And so, reluctantly at first, but then everybody joined in, ate the dead remains of the people that were around them and another thing they did. We made a pact. And we did what people do now. People give blood to friends, to family members. They make organ transplants, you know? And we made a pact, we said, okay, hand in hand. If I die, please use my body.
这样至少我们当中能有人活着离开这里。因此，这件事涉及同类相食，而且人们是自愿诉诸这一点的，这确实深深触动了我们的想象力，因为它真正引发了一个问题：在那种情况下你会怎么做？你也会跨越这条最严重的禁忌之线吗？我发现有趣的一点是，当我个人思考他们的行为时，我并不一定对他们所做的事感到厌恶。就像如果你告诉我有人在啃他们邻居的手臂，
So at least one of us can get out of here. So the fact that this is about cannibalism and that the people willingly resorted to this is something which has really caught our imagination because it really leads to this question of of what would you do in that circumstance? Would you also traverse the line into this worst taboo? One of the things that I find interesting is that when I personally think about their behavior, I don't necessarily feel disgusted by what they did. In the same way that if you told me that someone was munching on their neighbors' arm,
这种由于环境所迫而不得不为之、你所采取的行为是唯一可能让你活下去的唯一途径时，这种状况改变了我对这是否令人恶心的看法。没错。只有当这是一种蓄意、不必要的行为时，它才真正令人恶心。就像你说的，你杀了自己的邻居，然后决定吃掉他们。
there's something about essentially having your hand forced by circumstances, you're acting in a way that is the only way you can possibly survive that changes the way I think about whether this is disgusting. Exactly. It's only really disgusting when it's a willful, unnecessary behavior. So like you said, you kill your neighbor and then decide to eat them.
但一个被逼入绝境、唯一能活下去的方式就是利用现成的事实——即这个人已经死了——来进行权宜之计，这有着本质的不同。但行为本身——吃掉死者，吃掉另一个死去的人——是一样的。这就是我们的大脑如何将一种行为从“可以接受”转变为“完全令人憎恶”的。
But someone who is forced into this situation and the only way that they can survive is by resorting to an opportunistic situation that the person's already dead. That's a lot different. But the act itself, eating someone who's dead, eating another dead human being, is the same. This is how our mind changes the behavior from being okay to something completely abhorrent.
蕾切尔，你描述了一个发生在20世纪90年代的案例。一名男子在向另一名男子求爱被拒后遭到殴打致死，当案件闹上法庭时，被告成功使用了所谓的“同性恋恐慌辩护”。你说这个观点植根于对厌恶的误解？所以这个观点意味着，在这个意义上利用同性恋恐慌辩护，
Rachel, you describe a case that took place in the 1990s. A man was stomp to death after propositioning another man, and when the case was taken to court, the defendant successfully used something known as the gay panic defense. You say this idea is rooted in a misconception about disgust? So this idea that, in this sense, using the gay panic defense,
在本案中，某人能够说服陪审团相信，这个男人向他提出同性恋求爱的想法是如此令人反感，以至于他产生杀害此人的动机在某种程度上是正当的。正如你所说，它在审判中确实成功了。现在我认为这个概念，所以这是一种道德化，它让人们对谋杀行为减少批判，
so in this case, someone was able to convince the jury that the idea of this man, someone was able to convince the jury that the idea of this man making a homosexual advance to him was so repugnant that being motivated to kill this person was somehow justified. And like you said, it actually was successful in the trial. Now the concept that I think, so this is sort of, this is moralizing and this is getting people to become less judgmental towards the act of murder Because of the fact that they felt a kind of a sympathy towards the feeling of a version that this person must have had and therefore this sort of Outburst of rage is somehow justified
因为人们对这个人必然感到的厌恶情绪产生了一种同情，因此这种暴怒在某种程度上就显得情有可原了。这件事的不同之处在于——我认为这是关于厌恶的一个有趣点，它区别于人们经常将它与之混淆的“愤怒”——厌恶是关于退缩、远离、逃避那个让你感到恶心的刺激源。如果一个人真的对另一个人感到恶心，他们是绝对不会想扑到对方身上去把对方活活打死、弄得满身是血以及其他东西的，因为如果你已经感到恶心了，这样做只会让人觉得更恶心。相反，如果我真的很愤怒，如果我对某事怒不可遏，我就会发起攻击，我会冲上去，我会将你摧毁，哪怕沾满你的血肉也无所谓，因为我正处于狂怒之中。所以，认为这是出于厌恶的观点是错误的，
The thing that's different about this and I think this is an interesting point about Disgust in what makes it different from anger, which I think it's often confused with, is that disgust is about recoiling from, moving away from, avoiding the stimulus that's making you disgust it. And if someone were truly disgusted by somebody else, they would not want to get all over them and beat them to get death and get their blood and everything else all over them because that would be even more disgusting if you're already disgusted. Instead, if I'm really angry, if I'm enraged by something, then I attack, then I approach, then I can demolish you and get all covered in you and it doesn't matter because I'm just in a rage. So really, the idea about this being discussed is wrong and
实际情况是：这个人受到了冒犯——无论是在道德上、个人层面上还是其他任何方面——并被激怒到了如此地步，以至于他想要谋杀这个人。因此，以这种方式使用“厌恶”的概念其实是有瑕疵的。蕾切尔，恐同症的那个例子让我想到了一个观点。在几乎你走访的每一个社会中，你都能看到以社会阶层为蓝本的厌恶模式。在许多国家，富人会厌恶穷人，或者高种姓厌恶低种姓，或者本土公民厌恶外国人。你认为是什么解释了这一点？这与某种更具潜伏性的东西有关，它与我们对社会环境以及身处其中之人的感受有关。
what it was, is this person was affronted, you know, somehow morally, personally, whatever the case might be, and incited into such a rage that then he wanted to is this person was affronted, you know, somehow morally, personally, whatever the case might be, and incited into such a rage that then he wanted to murder this person. So the idea of using disgust in this way is actually flawed. So that example of homophobia, Rachel, makes me think about an idea. In almost every society you go to, you see patterns of disgust that are modeled on social hierarchies. In many countries you have the rich who are disgusted by the poor or upper caste who are
这种观点认为，外国人、陌生人等等是对我们社会正常秩序的威胁，而这随后又不知何故与我们关于污染和保护自身的观念联系在了一起。其逻辑是，这在某种程度上为种族偏见和其他种族偏见提供了正当理由和合理化依据，因为如果我们远离不熟悉的事物
disgusted by lower caste or people who are native citizens being disgusted by foreigners. What do you think explains this? It has to do with something more insidious and that's related to our feelings about our social environment and the people that are in it. And the idea that foreigners and strangers and so forth are threats to our social normal order, and that that then becomes somehow connected to our ideas about contamination and protecting us somehow. And the idea is that this somehow justifies and rationalizes racial prejudices and other kinds of prejudices, because if we stay away from the unfamiliar
和外国事物——因为我们不知道那些移民，你知道的，他们可能会携带疾病。事实上，疾病经常被用作反移民宣传的一种手段。当某种事物与他们是否真正能让我们生病之间没有任何联系时，这种做法却在某种程度上为针对他们的负面态度提供了正当理由。在我们生活的很大一部分时间里，厌恶感感觉就像是一种本能。当我们看到厨房台面上的蟑螂或垃圾桶里腐烂的食物时，
and the foreign, because we don't know what those immigrants, you know, they could be diseased. And in fact, disease was often used as a way of anti-immigrant propaganda. This somehow justifies negative attitude towards them when there is no relationship between their ability to actually make a sick or not. In much of our life, disgust feels instinctive. When we see a cockroach and a kitchen counter or smell rotten food in the trash can,
我们的反感感觉像是天生硬编码在基因里的。但蕾切尔说，事实并非如此。我们的厌恶感是后天习得的。接下来我们将探讨这个观点。心理学家蕾切尔·赫茨表示，让我们感到恶心的事物不仅揭示了许多关于我们文化的秘密，还极大地揭示了我们的大脑。她记起了自己童年时代的一次很有教育意义的经历。当时我们正坐在车里，那是一个美丽晴朗的夏日午霾，车窗摇下，你知道的，我们正开过田野，四周的一切都非常美好。我母亲从前座说：“哦，我好喜欢那个味道！”于是当我也
our revulsion feels hardwired. But Rachel says it's not. Our sense of disgust is learned. We explore that idea next. Psychologist Rachel Hurr says the things that disgust us not only reveal a lot about our culture, they reveal a great deal about our minds. She remembers an instructive episode from her own childhood. As we were driving in the car and it was a beautiful sunny summer day and the windows were rolled down and there were you know we were going by fields and everything was very pretty. My mother from the front seat said oh I love that smell and so as I
在闻着同样的气味时，我视野里所有美好的东西都在，而我深爱的母亲说“我好喜欢那个味道”，我便心想：好吧，这一定是个很棒的味道！然而几年后我才知道，对那个气味做出那样的回应是一个非常大的错误。原来那个味道是臭鼬。所以在周围有一群小孩子的操场上，当我脱口而出“我好喜欢那个味道”时，
was smelling the same thing and all kinds of nice things were in my visual scene and my mother who I love said I love that smell I thought okay this is a great smell and I then learned a few years later that saying that in response that smell was a very big mistake. So the smell turned out to be skunk. So when I said, I love that smell on the playground with all bunch of little kids around me
他们纷纷喊道：“咦，真恶心，那是臭鼬！”“你太恶心了”云云，然后纷纷跑开了。同样的，我也变成了那个“臭鼬”，因为他们全都从我身边跑开了。我意识到那并不是社会上得体的言论，于是我在很长一段时间里都把这事藏在心里。但事实证明我并不孤单。实际上确实有人喜欢臭鼬的味道，这也引出了关于我们嗅觉的一些有趣的事情。事实上，我们并不是所有人都在以同一种方式闻到臭鼬的气味。因此，无论是我们的大脑，还是我们的鼻子对构成臭鼬气味的化学物质的反应方式，其实都是因人而异的。
and they went, ew, disgusting, that skunk. Oh, you're so gross and so forth and ran away from me. Again, so I become now the skunk, because they all ran away from me. I realized that was not the socially appropriate thing to say and so I kept that to myself for quite a while. But it turns out I'm not alone. There are actually people who like the smell of skunk and that also leads into something interesting about our sense of smell. In fact, we don't all smell skunk in the same way. So both are minds and the way our noses in fact react to the chemical that makes up skunk is different.
所以，除非你有一个同卵双胞胎，否则你鼻子里的受体其实是独属于你自己的，没有任何其他人与你共享，尽管它们有很多重叠之处。因此，从我们闻到臭鼬时并非所有人都在闻到同一样东西这个角度来看，我们鼻子里的受体和我们大脑的工作方式……你知道的，我们可能在闻到不同的东西，但我也觉得这个故事真正令人着迷的地方在于，
So unless you have an identical twin, your receptors in your nose are actually only yours and nobody else shares them, even though there's a lot of overlap. So by the idea that we're all not smelling the same thing when we smell skunk, that the receptors in our noses and the way our brains work. You know, we might be smelling different things, but it's also what I find really fascinating
关于厌恶，有太多东西其实都是后天习得的。你听到了母亲的话，你在母亲和周围的美丽风景之间建立了某种联系，你在某种程度上学会了将一种强烈气味判定为积极的气味还是消极的气味。在许多方面，这与我们大多数人对厌恶的看法背道而驰。我们认为它是一种与生俱来的驱动力——如果我发现某样东西很恶心，当你闻到它时，你也会觉得它同样恶心。所以我觉得这提供了一个极好的切入点来思考厌恶的概念，那就是：它是必须后天习得的本能。
about the story is that there is so much about disgust that is actually learned. You heard your mother, you have an association between your mother and the beautiful scenery around you, and you learn in some ways whether something that's a strong smell is a positive smell or a negative smell. And in many ways, this runs counter to the way most of us think, think about disgust. We think of it as being this innate drive that if I find something disgusting, you're going to smell it and you're going to find a disgusting as well. So I think that brings up a great way to think about the idea of disgust, and it is that it is the instinct that has to be learned.
因此，一旦我们学会了什么是恶心的事物，我们就会对它产生厌恶感，比如，排泄物、如厕训练、便便等等。我们不会去质疑它是否恶心，尤其是当这些东西来自别人时——这也是意义和情境发挥作用的地方。但我们从一开始并不觉得它恶心。也就是说，我们并不是天生就觉得便便很恶心。事实上，许多婴儿既喜欢玩便便，也喜欢便便的气味。
So once we learn what something disgusting is, we then feel disgusted by it, like, for instance, bodily products and toilet training and poop and so forth. We don't have a question about whether or not it's disgusting, especially if it's from somebody else, where also is where meaning and context come into play. But we did not think it was disgusting from the get go. So that is to say we were not hardwired or born thinking that poop was gross. In fact, many infants both like to play with poop. They like the smell of poop.
他们对事物的反应并没有成人那种社区意义上的正面或负面之分。事实上，我喜欢做一个很好的示范，那就是展示婴儿闻到汗袜子、呕吐物的气味与闻到香草气味时的面部表情。有些婴儿在闻到汗袜子和呕吐物的气味时，会露出灿烂的微笑；而另一些婴儿在闻到香草气味时，则会做出
They don't have any reactions to things. For instance, that adults in the same community think of as positive or negative. In fact, a great demonstration I like to do is showing these facial expressions of babies getting either the smell of sort of sweaty socks and vomit versus the smell of vanilla. And some babies' faces to the sweaty socks and vomit are making big smiley faces. And others to the smell of vanilla are making
我们所谓的“厌恶表情”。因此，无论是对气味的反应，还是对恶心事物的反应，都没有什么是生来就注定的。但一旦我们了解了其含义，我们就会坚守这种看法，除非情境让它变得非常混乱，或者情境改变了我们感知事物的方式。我非常喜欢这种观点：在许多方面，我们的厌恶观念都是被构建出来的。据我所知，美国人喜欢冬青口味的口香糖，但英国人可没那么喜欢。所以在英国，冬青薄荷几乎只用在马桶清洁产品和一些药用软膏中，比如你在身体疼痛时涂抹在皮肤上的那种东西。
what we would call disgust faces. So there's nothing hardwired about the reaction either to smells or to things that are disgusting. But once we learn what the meaning is, we then stick to it, except for when the context can make it very confusing or the context changes the way we perceive something. I love this idea that in many ways our notions of disgust are constructed. I understand that Americans like winter green flavor chewing gum, but people in Britain not so much. So in the UK, winter green mint is used exclusively in toilet cleaning products and in some medicinal bombs, like things you would rub on your skin if you're in pain.
因此，这种气味要么与身处病痛中联系在一起，要么与清洁马桶联系在一起。所以这绝不是什么好印象。然而在美国，这种气味被用在糖果和口香糖中。它与甜味联系在一起，而甜味在本质上是积极的。所以“品尝甜味”加上“闻到某种即将带来美好体验的东西”结合在了一起。当闻到这种气味时，我们并没有任何关于清理浴室或经受病痛的联想。因此，作为我们对它所习得的联系以及其所代表含义的一种功能，这种气味本身完全是中性的、不具任何倾向性的——它本身没有正面或负面的含义——但由于这些习得的联系，它变得美妙或变得糟糕。
And so the smell is connected to either being in pain or cleaning the toilet. So not good. In the U.S., however, the scent is used in candies and in gums. It's connected to the taste of sweet and sweet actually is innately positive. So tasting sweet plus smelling something that's going to be good. And we don't have any connection to cleaning the bathroom or being in pain when we smell this odor. And so as a function of the connections that we have learned to it and what the meaning is, this odor which in and of itself is totally, you know, agnostic, it doesn't have meaning one way or the other becomes good or becomes bad as a function of that.
所以英国人和美国人在冬青这个话题上存在分歧。但我绝对确信，当谈到吃……昆虫时，他们一定会达成共识。开始吃吧。我的心跳得好快，哦天哪。它们看起来像蟋蟀。这没什么好粉饰的。如果我再待在这儿，我都要吐了。哦，我不想吃。这是我们的一些NPR同事在我们将一盘
So the British and the Americans are divided on the subject of Wintergreen. But I'm absolutely sure they'd come together when it comes to eating... bugs. Eating happened. My heart's pounding, oh my god. They look like crickets. There's no sugar coating. I'm about to throw up if I stay here. Oh, I don't want to do it. Those are reactions from a couple of our NPR co-workers when we presented them with a
风干蟋蟀摆在他们面前并要求他们咬一口时的反应。我能拿我的水瓶吗？能给我来一杯压惊饮料吗？只要它们在外面，我对昆虫完全没问题。我不确定当它们进到我嘴里时我是不是还能这么淡定。太恶心了。这是昆虫。你看它。到处都是外骨骼，还有断了的腿。
plate of dried crickets and asked them to take a bite. Can I get the whole of my water bottle, can I have a chaser? I'm cool bugs as long as they're outside. I'm not sure how cool I am with them being my mouth. It's disgusting. It's insects. Look at it. There's exoskeletons everywhere, pieces of legs.
这太Gross（恶心）了。人们居然吃这东西。到处都是外骨骼，还有断了的腿。这太Gross了。人们居然吃这东西。有几件事让我们对昆虫感到厌恶。其中之一就是我们不认为它们是食物。现在，有些文化，尤其是东南亚的文化，确实把各种各样的昆虫当作食物。如果你去泰国，你会看到市场上展出的大马士革嘶鸣蟑螂，人们实际上是在买它们来当饭吃，并用各种方式烹调它们。尽管我个人并不了解，但据说这可以相当美味。
This is gross. People eat this. There's a couplekeletons everywhere, pieces of legs. This is gross. People eat this. There's a couple of things which disgust us about bugs. One of them is that we don't consider them to be food. Now, there are cultures, especially in Southeast Asia, that do consider all kinds of bugs as food. And if you were to go to Thailand, you'd see Madagascar hissing cockroaches on display
但“什么是食物”这个概念是一个非常有趣的命题，因为它再次说明了厌恶是如何后天习得的——当我们决定某样东西是可食用的时，吃它就变得顺理成章了，而其他文化对此有不同的看法。关于昆虫的另一件事是，它们的移动方式似乎与我们不喜欢它们的潜在厌恶原因之一有关，而这其实在某种程度上
in the market where people are actually buying them to eat them up for meals and prepare them in all kinds of ways, which apparently, although I don't know personally, can be quite delicious. But the idea of what food is is a really interesting concept because this again speaks to how disgust is learned and when we decide that something is edible, then it's okay to eat and other cultures think differently about that. The other thing about bugs is that they move in a way that seems to be related to one of the aspects of discussing underlying why we don't like them, and this is actually somewhat
与体液有关。昆虫以一种抽搐的、滑溜的或黏糊糊的方式移动。而这类东西实际上与我们同样感到厌恶的身体分泌物有相似之处。例如，对蛞蝓感到厌恶，就与蛞蝓在视觉上类似于粪便这一事实有关。因此，在我们对昆虫的认知与我们厌恶的体液之间，存在着一种连续的关联。因此，昆虫令人厌恶的原因有很多。在你书中有个吸引我眼球的观点是，即便在同一个国家的不同历史时期，我们对什么是恶心的态度也发生了或能够发生巨大的变化。我了解到，几个世纪前的龙卷风……不对，几个世纪前的龙卷风……几世纪前的马萨诸塞州，龙虾可不是现在这个样子的。
connected to bodily fluids. So bugs move in a kind of a jerky or a slithery or a slimy kind of way. And those kinds of things actually have a similarity to body products that we are also disgusted by. So being disgusted by slugs, for instance, is to do the fact that slugs are similar, visually, to feces. So there is this kind of continuum about our association between what bugs are and what bodily fluids are that were disgusted by. So there's a variety of reasons what bugs are and what bodily fluids are that were
不，龙虾当时其实被视为海里的害虫，只适合奴隶吃。事实上当时还爆发了一场奴隶起义，抗议把龙虾作为食物每周给人们吃三次以上完全是一种残酷而不人道的惩罚。而今天，我们可能会说：“哦，能吃得起龙虾每周吃三次，是多么幸运啊！”所以可以想象，也许在几十年后，或者从现在算起的几个世纪后，我们看待吃蟑螂和蟋蟀的态度会与今天截然不同。事实上，有些人会认为昆虫是极其高效的蛋白质来源，它们数量繁多，而且在某些方面，食用昆虫实际上可能对环境保护大有裨益。我个人是个素食主义者，所以我不知道自己是否会去尝试吃蟋蟀和
disgusted by. So there's a variety of reasons why bugs are disgusting. One of the things in your book that caught my eye was even in the same country in different periods of time, our attitudes about what's disgusting have changed or can change enormously. I understand that a few centuries ago lobster was not quite seen the way that it was in few centuries ago, lobster was not quite seen the way that it was in Massachusetts. No, lobster was actually considered vermin of the sea and only suitable for slaves. And in fact, there was this slave uprising against the idea that it was completely cruel and unusual punishment to give people lobster to eat more than three times a week.
蟑螂，但可以推测，我们对待食用昆虫的态度确实可能会改变。绝对会。所以，另一个让龙虾变得令人恶心、毫无吸引力的原因在于，它是奴隶的食物，是囚犯的食物。因此这些人，他们是——在人类的阶层中，他们是低人一等的坏人。因此他们吃那些我们可能认为是恶心的东西是可以接受的，但对于我——这个高贵的人（无论我如何看待自己）——来说是不可接受的。而现在，我们看待昆虫的方式也类似于此。所以那些与我们不同的人、那些为了生存不得不诉诸最后手段的人，他们会自甘堕落去吃昆虫。
And today, we might say, oh, how lucky to be able to afford to have lobster three times a week. So it's conceivable then maybe in a few decades or maybe in a couple of centuries from now, we will think of eating cockroaches and crickets very differently than we do today. In fact, there are some people who would argue that insects are a very efficient source of protein and they're plentiful and in some ways consuming insects might actually be good for the environment in all kinds of different ways. I'm personally a vegetarian so I don't know if I'll ever subscribe to eating crickets and
但如果我们彻底改变看法，如果我们为这个故事重新赋予道德内涵，不把吃昆虫看作是一种堕落的事情或最后的无奈之举，而是把它变成一件拯救地球、充满美德的事情，那么我们实际上可以把它变成一件非常积极的事情。好吧，我们的一些同事在手里拿着蟋蟀时，一开始都退缩了。你越是看着它的眼睛，你就越不想吃它。但在第一口咬下去之后，恐惧和厌恶的表情就消失了。干杯。干杯。吃起来有点像薯片。挺好吃的。有点土腥味。就像某种葵花籽之类的东西。对，就像吃一盘这种东西
cockroaches but presumably our attitudes towards eating insects could change. Absolutely. So the idea also, one of the things that made lobster disgusting and unappealing is that it was slave food, it was prisoner food. So these people, these are, these are bad people in the kind of the hierarchy of humans. And therefore it's okay for them to eat things that are possibly, that we would consider disgusting, but not okay for me, you know, the elevated person, whatever I think of myself as being. And right now, the way we think about insects is similar to that. So people who are not like us, people who have to resort to the last measure as possible for survival, they're going to debase themselves to eat insects.
在我那小小的……除了整只的蟋蟀，我们还提供了用蟋蟀粉制作的美味蛋白质棒样品。我选了花生酱和巧克力味的。如果你不告诉别人这是用蟋蟀做的，他们根本尝不出来。挺好吃的。里面又没有大块的蟋蟀，所以我挺喜欢的。一点也不赖。我正努力让自己不要显得那么……像个美国人，你知道的，因为其他所有人都在吃蟋蟀。能够挑剔食物是一种奢侈。从最基本的层面来说，如果你除了身边死去的同伴或地板上的蟑螂之外没有别的可吃，那么你就不会对这些东西感到恶心，因为你必须为了生存而吃。所以，能够说“不，我宁愿不吃那个死人或那只蟑螂，我宁愿吃汉堡、牛排或那盘精心烹制的波多贝罗蘑菇”，这是一种特权。
But if we think about it entirely differently, so if we remoralize the story, and instead make eating insects about saving the planet and Make it a virtuous thing to do rather than somehow a debase thing to do or a last resort thing to do We could in fact make it a very positive thing Well some of our co-workers shrank it first when they held the cricket in their hand The more you look in his eyes the the less you want to eat it. The looks of fear and disgust faded after the first crunch. Cheers. Cheers. It's just like chips kind of. It's good. It's a little earthy. It's like some flour seed or something. Yeah, like a basket of these
你们在这里最先听到了：蟋蟀就是新龙虾。
like before my little pung. Along with the whole crickets, we also provided samples of delectable protein bars made of cricket flour. I chose peanut butter and chocolate. If you didn't tell people this was a cricket, they wouldn't know. It's good. It's not like there's big chunks of cricket in it, so I like it. Not bad at all. I'm trying to not be so like... American, you know, because like everyone else eats crickets. It is a luxury to be able to be disgusted. From the very basic level that if you don't have anything else to eat other than someone
在我们生活的诸多领域中，厌恶感和心态息息相关。那些让我们退避三舍的事物，换个角度也能变得充满吸引力。现在，请敲起鼓来。镜头回到腐臭运动鞋大赛现场。2018年度臭脚大王运动鞋大赛的冠军得主是——亨特！亨特，快上台来！
who's dead beside you or the cockroach on the floor, then you just do not get disgusted by that because you have to do it in order to survive. So it's a privilege to be able to say, no, I'd rather not have that dead person or that cockroach. I'd rather have that hamburger or the steak or that beautifully prepared dish of Portobello mushroom. You heard it here first. Crickets are the new lobster. ["The New Lobster"]
站在正中间！来自阿拉斯加州鹰河镇的8岁男孩亨特·哈姆将这一头衔收入囊中，并将他的鞋子加入了恶臭名人堂。他的母亲劳伦表示，亨特加入了一个家族传奇。我去年可能没从阿拉斯加拿到冠军。我不知道这是否真的是你想出名的代价——臭脚，但我们乐在其中。我们的名人评委蕾切尔·赫茨将为我们对比赛结果进行专业分析。
Disgust and so many realms of our lives is about our mindset. The things that repulse us in a different perspective can become attractive. And now, drum roll. Back at the rotten sneakers contest. The winner of this year's 2018 odor eaters run sneaker contest goes to Hunter! Hunter, come on up!
厌恶以及我们生活中的许多领域都与我们的心态有关。从不同的角度来看，那些让我们反感的事物可能会变得很有吸引力。现在，请敲击鼓声。回到烂球鞋大赛。2018年度“除臭专家”臭球鞋大赛的冠军得主是亨特！亨特，快上来！
Stand right here! 8-year-old Hunter Ham from Eagle River, Alaska, takes home the title, and he adds a shoes to the Hall of Fumes. His mother Lauren says Hunter joins a family pantheon. I might not be cornered one last year from Alaska. I don't know if that's what you really want to be known for. Stinky feet, but we're having fun with it. Our celebrity judge Rachel Hers gives us the export analysis on the competition results.
站到这里来！来自阿拉斯加州鹰河镇的8岁男孩亨特·汉姆夺得了这一头衔，并将一双鞋加入了“臭气名人堂”。他的母亲劳伦表示，亨特加入了一个家族荣誉殿堂。去年我可能没有从阿拉斯加被逼入绝境。我不知道这是否真的是你想为人所知的事情。脚臭，但我们对此乐在其中。我们的名人评委雷切尔·赫尔斯为我们对比赛结果进行了专业分析。
So Alaska is almost always the worst in my experience every year because I think they have so much more outdoor play and they're usually fishing which is a really horrible smell when it's rotted and they're often more farm-based and so they usually have the worst sneakers of all. While the competition seems like pure silliness, the kids are actually learning something important. Hunter and the other finalists are getting a master class in what our culture deems to be disgusting.
根据我的经验，阿拉斯加几乎每年都是最差的，因为我认为他们的户外活动要多得多，他们通常在钓鱼，鱼烂掉时的气味非常糟糕，而且他们通常更偏向农场生活，因此他们的运动鞋通常是所有地方里面最脏的。虽然这场比赛看起来纯粹是胡闹，但孩子们实际上学到了一些重要的东西。亨特和其他决赛选手正在上一堂大师课，了解我们的文化认为什么是恶心的。
So young children are not very good at recognizing disgust faces. In fact, they often mistake the face of disgust with the face of anger and actually adults do as well, but not to the same extent. And children actually, again, have to learn what disgust really means. And it's only once they're able to understand themselves, the different levels of disgust, are they then able to recognize disgust in somebody else? Because when they see disgust, let's say in the face of an adult, they also recognize that it's in response to something.
因此，幼儿并不太擅长识别厌恶的表情。事实上，他们经常把厌恶的表情误认为是愤怒的表情，成年人其实也会这样，但程度没有那么深。而且孩子们同样需要重新学习厌恶的真正含义。只有当他们能够自己理解不同程度的厌恶时，他们才能识别别人脸上的厌恶情绪吗？因为当他们看到厌恶时，比方说在大人的脸上，他们也会意识到这是对某种情况的反应。
So just like your parent might make an angry face because you threw all your plate on the floor and banging your hands on the table or something like that. They may make a different face if you, you know, pee on the ground, for example. And the idea is that the child has to then make the association between, there is something that's just happened in the environment and I'm seeing this face and that's what that face means. And the connection between that and discussed takes a lot longer to develop than it does between other sorts of things like anger or fear or happiness.
就像你的父母可能会因为你把盘子里的东西全扔在地板上、用手拍打桌子或诸如此类的事情而做出愤怒的表情一样。如果你，比如说，在地板上小便，他们可能会做出不同的表情。这个想法是，孩子随后必须建立这样的联系：环境中刚刚发生了某事，我看到了这个表情，这就是那个表情的意思。而这种联系与厌恶之间的建立，比愤怒、恐惧或快乐等其他事情之间的建立需要更长的时间。
Rachel Hers is the author of That's Disgusting and the Scent of Desire. She also had a book out at the end of 2017, why you eat, what you eat. Richard Hurts, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a pleasure, Sankar. Thank you for having me. This episode was produced by Parth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen and Jenny Schmidt. Field production assistance this week by Monique Laborde. Arun Sanghiros today are the brave NPR colleagues who signed up to eat crickets for our show.
瑞秋·赫兹是《那是恶 disgusting》和《欲望的气味》的作者。她还在2017年底出版了一本书《你为什么吃你所吃的东西》。理查德·赫兹，感谢你今天来到Hidden Brain节目。这是我的荣幸，桑卡尔。谢谢邀请我。本期节目由帕斯·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括雷纳·科恩和珍妮·施密特。本周的外景制作助理是莫妮克·拉博德。阿伦·桑吉罗斯今天是勇敢的NPR同事，他们报名为我们的节目吃蟋蟀。
They are Ninjury Eaton, Michael King, Sam Hoysington, Kumari Devarajan, Dutran, Alex Curley, Alex McCall, Mayas Turn, CJ Rikulin, Ramteen Aralui, Adam Winters, and Kelly Jones. There was one other NPR staffer who partook of the delicacies we served in the creation of this episode, producer Paz Shah ate some of the crickets. What did you think, Paz? Not as grislobs, sir. But I mean it wasn't bad. I liked it.
他们是Ninjury Eaton、Michael King、Sam Hoysington、Kumari Devarajan、Dutran、Alex Curley、Alex McCall、Mayas Turn、CJ Rikulin、Ramteen Aralui、Adam Winters和Kelly Jones。还有另一位NPR工作人员品尝了我们在制作本期节目时提供的美食，制作人帕斯·沙阿吃了一些蟋蟀。你觉得怎么样，帕斯？没那么恶心，先生。但我的意思是它并不坏。我喜欢它。
Did you eat the legs and head and everything? Oh, I guess, yeah it's just one bite. Oh my god. If you like today's show, please share it with a friend. If you feel so inclined, like Parth, you can discuss the show over a cricket or two. I'm Shankar Vidantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你把腿、头和所有东西都吃了吗？哦，我想，是的，就咬了一口。哦，天哪。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请与朋友分享。如果你愿意的话，就像帕斯一样，你可以一边吃一两只蟋蟀一边讨论节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。